[Music]
rejuvenation
say it a million times
then say it a million more and the word
you will have said two million times is
uh no rejuvenation
because that's what we're talking about
today
specifically how this relates to human
rejuvenation and the three main
strategies
why well in case you haven't heard the
news outsource labs has taken over
twitter
and they're going to be doing some cool
work
as are many other researchers and other
companies that have also entered the
space
but before we dive into the three main
strategies what do we even mean by
rejuvenation
well rejuvenation refers to reversal of
aging so it differs from strategies that
target direct causes of mortality and
also from strategies that slow down or
attenuate the biological age process
i've always well always since i first
saw this figure liked this figure here
because it demonstrates how rejuvenation
differs from duro-protective mechanisms
if aging is akin to gravity then like
the flow of water during protective
strategies are like dams and canals that
slow down the flow rate whilst
rejuvenation strategies are more like
water pumps
however it may not be that clear-cut for
some strategies as to whether it is
during protective or rejuvenating
one may see signs of rejuvenation at a
single cell level or a tissue but at the
organism and functional level such as
royalty measurements it may appear only
to slow down the process
secondly we would need reliable ways of
measuring biological age to see how
these strategies impact it
but anyway enough with semantics and
definitions let's look at what are
considered the three main rejuvenating
strategies
so firstly factors in the bloods or not
some of the earliest indications that we
could manipulate aging came from studies
conducted in the 1900s known as
heterochronic parabyosis
simply surgically joining two animals
together such that they share a
circulatory system
sounds a bit grim
but it provided an experimental system
to test for systemic effects on aging in
different tissues since the circulatory
system is body wide
the earliest work was published in the
late 1950s and early 1960s where here
they could perform the experiments by
combining young and old rats
a more systemic study conducted in 1972
showed that when older members of a
female heterochronic pair outlived
single female controls and homo chronic
female control parabolas
so this hinted that there might be
something in the young blood that was
enabling these older female rats to live
longer
but as correctly pointed out in the
study that increase of life expectancy
is not equivalent to decelerated aging
the younger member of the heterochronic
pair may enhance survival of the older
by protecting it against disease not
directly attributable to senescence
but much of this work has now been
revisited now with newer techniques and
resources
and for a while it was thought that
there must be factors in the young
bloods that have declined in the old
this stemmed from a 2005 publication by
the combo lab where heterochronic
parabiosis ameliorated
phenotypes and in a study in 2020
showing that young blood plasma
fractions were first epigenetic asian
rats
so with these tools we can now see age
reversal
it may be a relief to hear that in this
latter paper they didn't have to fuse
the circulatory system together
and another approach that also avoids
this parabiosis problem is plasma
dilution
this builds on the idea that the
benefits from heterochronic parabolosis
may have also come from effectively
diluting the bad factors in the old
blood
and work again coming from the combo lab
showed this in 2020 whereby diluting
aged plasma and mice with saline and
albumin rejuvenated the three tissue
lines
so they saw signatures of cell
replication which more closely matches
what are seen in younger mice there is
still more data to collect though to
really evaluate if this is age reversal
but since replacement of blood plasma is
already something pretty safe so i guess
time consuming in humans it hopefully
shouldn't take too long to see these
results
but it is worth mentioning that it is
very likely that a combination of both
additional factors from young blood and
dilution of old blood is
beneficial but as i said more work would
be needed to tease these two aspects
apart and to further confirm the
presence of a rejuvenating effect
so to the second strategy cellular
reprogramming
now many of you probably associate this
with the yamanaka factors and rightly so
back in 2006 senior yamanaka published
an out landmark study whereby the
introduction of four factors the
yamanaka factors oskm
when expressed and differentiated mouse
cells could reverse them to pluripotent
stem cells
cells that have the potential to divide
continuously but also differentiate
so they were called induced pluripotent
stem cells
hence this is where your programming
comes in you've effectively altered a
cell's identity
and so by measuring the age of these
reprogrammed cells
again here using epigenetic age which is
based on dna methylation marks a
decrease in age was seen
so that's pretty cool we can turn a
specialized cell into something younger
but what does that mean that's just one
cell well a 2020 paper showed that the
use of three yamanaka factors osk
allowed old mice to regain eyesight and
a new preprint has shown that a single
transient expression of oskm and
naturally aged mice reverse aging in the
pancreas liver spleen and blood
i'll cover this work in more detail when
it's officially published so you want to
make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss that
but moreover you can use these induced
pluripotent stem cells to make entirely
new embryos but this latter paper
reinforces how unleashing this
replicated potential also comes with its
own risks cancer development
and so ultimately to get better control
over these exciting mechanisms it is
best to understand how referring the
identity of a cell could reverse age
and can other factors or combination of
factors be found and will that
combination vary depending on tissue
type
and so instead of yamanaka factors you
may now hear them referred to more
generally as reprogramming factors
but small molecules potentially could
also work
and so as you can probably tell there
are many unanswered questions which is
part of the reason why there's been so
much excitement around the outsource
labs announcement and the rise of more
rejuvenation companies
and so the last strategy
understanding the endogenous
now the strategy is a little different
but nonetheless still interesting partly
because there is much still left to
uncover and is the reason why all of us
were young when we were born that is the
natural rejuvenation that must occur
after fertilization to erase damage from
the egg and sperm from our parents that
give rise to our fresh face cells
recent development of the first single
cell epigenetic clock
single cell age has also provided data
now to support a rejuvenation process in
early development
and so we know that this is a
rejuvenating event the question is what
are the molecular mechanisms involved
part of this age referral may come from
telomere extension as there's some
previous work showing that growing mice
from embryonic stem cells that have been
passaged from wall times in culture
which effectively meant that they had
longer telomeres
enabled the elongation of lifespan with
low incidence of disease
but also as you can see in this figure
early developments there is lots of
rapid division and growth which also
means opportunities for damage to get
diluted
so similar to above with the plasma
dilution but on a very different scale
but yeah understanding the mechanism
could be useful down the line
therapeutically
so to quote from this recent review
article
much of the biological underpinnings of
rejuvenation remain enigmatic and the
current side effects induced by some of
these interventions particularly
reprogramming currently prevent their
translational application
so outsource labs and the other
companies have many challenges ahead
will they succeed who knows but what i
am sure of is that we will uncover some
interesting biology along the way
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening
you